[Music]
all right um crash that's the name that
i see here
okay
in fact
yeah craft
the question is for you to explain first
corinthians chapter 14 verse 34 and i
believe this is in context to women
being silent in church let me just read
the text first
chapter 14
34.
if you can explain
that as i
the word of the lord
says
your women keep silence in church in the
churches for it is not permitted unto
them to speak but they are commanded to
be under obedience as also saith the law
i smile because a lot of people use that
text to silence women and say they can't
speak in the church now that's one of
the most troublesome texts in the bible
and i've not yet seen a definitive uh
statement of that i've not yet seen a
definitive treatment of that verse
let me say this because you must lose
reason when studying the bible let's
switch together
we know that there are women leaders in
the bible i didn't say a women priest i
said women leaders
deborah was a judge and the king came to
her for counsel and wisdom judges
chapter 4 chapters 4 and 5 when fighting
the canaanites deborah told him what to
do deborah would instruct the people
that now they have no church buildings
back then but the church is not a
building it is the gathering of god's
people deborah would instruct god's
people she was not told to keep silent
we have in uh philippians chapter four
verse two and three i beseech your
audience and beseech synthetic that they
be of the same mind in the lord and i
entreat you true your fellow help those
women which labored with me in the
gospel there were two men who work with
paul it is not unreasonable to assume
that they help in preaching the word we
have aquila and priscilla in acts 18
they took apollos who was very eloquent
but did not know the word very well you
read from verse 24 onward and they
taught him the word because
priscilla who was the wife to acquire
was very versed in the word and so here
was she teaching a preacher if the bible
does not teach that women cannot occupy
opposition the puppet and preach
so whatever first corinthians 14 34 says
it cannot contradict other parts of the
scripture where women clearly spoke for
god
and so so i cannot give go anywhere any
anymore beyond that
to give you a of uh an authoritative
treaties on that verse but i can tell
you that there are women in the bible
who spoke for god so however you look at
first corinthians 14 14 34 it cannot
contradict those clear passages where
women obviously spoke for god
i did not say that the bible says women
should be priests i was said that i said
they were leaders in the church and they
spoke
and there's nothing to keep a woman from
speaking the bible says what prophesies
she should cover ahead prophesize me
speaking for god whether to one person
or to a group the bible understands that
women will prophesy or speak for god
we can't use first corinthians 14 34 to
silence them because on the surface it
looks like it is saying women should not
speak in church
amen
you